earlier we spoke with Stoneman Douglas
high school freshman Kelsey friend she
says that her life was saved by her
geography teacher Scott beagle who died
trying to shield his students from the
gunman Kelsey we are all thinking of you
today because unfortunately you and your
classmates have to get used to a new
normal
are you ready to go back to school today
how are you feeling I am ready to go
back to school but I'm feeling a little
scared and a little nervous like right
now my heart's pounding which is a
hearing cup feel close past behind me
and it's reminded me of that day Kelsey
are you planning to do anything are you
just trying to get through the day or
will there be a part of the school
you'll go to or something you'll do to
mark what's a difficult return today
they're not teaching I think we're all
just gonna talk about what had happened
that day and that's all that I really
know I don't even know what my schedule
is not I don't know where my classes are
because I had three classes in the
freshman building and I don't know where
any of them are right now Kelsey you say
you're alive today because of the
heroism of your geography teacher Scott
beagle you promised to call his mom
every day why is that been important to
you to do it's been important to me
because I I just want to have his spirit
alive and it's calling his mom and doing
what he did when he was alive does that
then I'm gonna do it as well to keep him
with me for the rest of my life
Kelsey during this period what's been
the most helpful thing to you to get
through this unimaginably hard time well
the one thing that got me through the
hard time was just being with my family
especially with my mom she she always
comfort me during when I was crying I
did cry a lot because I did lose a
friend as well
how are you processing all of this you
know it's been it's been a very short
time since this incident happened I mean
you all went to a normal day at school
to now being a national news story and
I'm wondering how you're processing all
of it and what your thinking is you sit
here now that some days have passed when
I'm released I what I really think of
what had happen
and having it all over the news I just
wish it was a dream like one bad dream
that I can just wake up from and now
knowing that I'm up going back to school
I'm realizing it's not no dream that
actually happened which is hitting me
harder than it when it happened
can't see a lot of your classmates have
talked about safety and gun control have
you been interested in that part of the
conversation or is that not something
you're interested in that's something
I'm very interested in because gun
violence and every part of our nation is
bad so having my friends from my school
speak out about it is pushing me through
what I had happen and it's very
interesting because we actually now have
a voice some of your classmates decided
not to go back to Stoneman at all did
you ever consider transferring to
another school and not going back to
your school
No I want to send some in Douglas high
school I don't imagine myself in any
other high school all right
Kelsey friend we thank you for joining
us we'll all be thinking of you and your
classmates today I can't imagine what
its gonna be like for them today
regardless of how you feel about gun
control
everybody is marveling about the
strength the poise and the resilience
and you're right Alex the resilience of
these I don't know that I could go back
and walk those hallways after what
they've been through their fortitude in
this moment is incredible and especially
since everything they're all the
security all the cameras all reminds of
that of that horrible day and yet at the
end she said I can't see myself anywhere
else which is probably the first act of
ownership of taking rican troll of this
school Jori them feel that way and I saw
a student in everyone the students that
said I just want to be back with my
friends just all want to get back there
well we wish them luck
we really do today